really the two Comics left in La it's
like the same guy and the two people
that are fighting for dominance of the
LA comedy scene right now are literally
indistinguishable from each other which
is weird and it's me and Matt Rife
[Laughter]
it's the same guy
and we're we're talking about the same
things and so what it really is is this
fight between these two brothers who are
the same yes to try to try to reach
these people Jesus Christ is this what
Matt looks like yeah that's what I look
like too it's these cameras you don't
have nice cameras that's the problem is
these [__] cameras
Rogan invested all the money in deer
antlers and not the cameras because
without the camera no but we're very
similar we look alike with the same type
of guy and it's weird it's weird and
it's just both of us in L.A like
fighting for like who's gonna do it
that's the photo is that a lion
that's the photo that where it's like so
it's hard to that's what La is right now
it's just me and this guy yeah fighting
for Supremacy yeah
being the same you know what I mean sure
my crowd is all women because they're
brilliant yeah
because they're very smart they're
Indica
women like the to the takes and I did a
show at me Shane Mullen and Big Jay who
was in Arena
all women came out in Hershey
Pennsylvania all women who voted for
Joseph Biden that's my audience women
who voted for Joseph Biden and I'm proud
do you uh do you and Matt get along or
is it pretty contentious no it's
like
10 just because
always tough to see your doppelganger
all the time and it's like it's like
it's like now Matt's actually an awesome
dude it's like a really sweet guy and
he's funny and awesome but
um and we do look different
so that's that's that's good I think
that's good it is so cute he's very he's
very attractive from a from a movie or
is that like a like
but I dated her and let me tell you
something about Kate Beck and shell you
go to dinner with her I mean you gotta
fill the conversation
oh
you're trying to talk to her about the
Ukraine you got another thing coming
she's got nothing
it's a joke we're all kidding oh no oh
my God is this real this is what I don't
know yeah run this is like there's this
comedy people are now this is truly
[__] reality TV show yeah well it is
listen
are getting laid I think that's cool
it's cool it's
cool comedy shows get too cool not too
cool not too cool it's not good no it
loses Colin Quinn said if economy gets
too cool it always loses for sure it
makes a lot of sense yeah for sure
that's why you gotta like you gotta kind
of lean you know we all want to be seen
a certain way look good and all this
stuff but you got to kind of lean into
your flaws a little bit if you're a
comic well lean into Humanity yeah I
think humanity is important I think
technology is obviously very important
but I also think that like the job of a
comic is to like kind of remember that
human beings exist yeah you know what I
mean yeah isn't that profound yeah
that's really good isn't that profound
that's the type of [__] I say that's the
dumbest [__] but it sounds good like
I'll be like the job of a comedian is to
remember that human beings exist you
know